[Music]
I love entertainment I love movies I
love TV shows the most recent thing I've
been much the stranger thinks I have to
say that I was like kind of worried that
the second season might not have been as
good but it was like amazing so
hopefully season threes on its way
oh I used to be really big [ __ ] oh now
you know that I'm in my mid 30s and I'm
seeing go I'm definitely more into the
rom-coms trying to get those those
fields out there think about Batman is
that he's just a regular dude he's he's
rich and he's a badass but he doesn't
have superpowers he's just dope I feel
like when I first watched it like the
first season when I first came out I was
like this is kind of like a different
unique story like I don't haven't really
seen this before I mean I grew up with
the home Alone's like that that was my
things actually I think I sort of lived
home alone with my parents and had three
younger brothers whenever there's a set
in Chicago and I recognize a building it
is it throws me back so it's a really
cool experience that whole dark night
series was like the best superhero
movies ever they're super dark and
gritty I think Christopher Nolan's an
awesome director they're just really
well done and much more my style I think
like a lot of the Marvel movies are
amazing but they're like blockbusters
and they're super kind of like cheesy
and spunky and I don't know I feel like
Batman was like raw and real I will
watch every rom-com even if it's
terrible and I'm I hate it I was like
this is terrible the acting is terrible
this girl she's she knew one's seen one
that's the guy she wanted but she's like
no no no he's not my type Bubba and then
they end up being a married but I sit
there and watch it every time it's
insane like typical girl but yeah I
definitely like more action actions good
you know to really just not make you
feel horrible it's you know you're in it
I love the sports montages you know I
love it when the athletes training and
gearing up for that big match or game
how can you choose one sports montage
like that's the best part of the movie
right there